I was with Akmal when
he was killed in Chad.
He died a hero for a
just and noble cause.
If it was so noble, perhaps
you should have died with him.
Look, I know it was rough.
But letting Andrew go
was the last shot we had.
Decision's on me.
Yeah, damn straight it is.
Bruno.
She did what she had to do.
You did the right thing.
You got something
to say to me?
I'm just wondering
whose back you've got--
hers or ours?
Bud, you have to move on.
I'm sorry, jefe.
But I can't do that.
I've never going to do that.
Ever since Rip died, you
have questioned every decision
that I have made for this team.
That has to stop.
Now.
Check this out.
It's a surf shop in Santa Cruz.
It's for sale.
You could do this.
We do this.
I'll think about it.
Show me some more pictures.
I need you back on the team.
Can you clear a medical,
then be good to go?
I'll be good to go.
Vern.
Your clearance
has been revoked.
You shot that man in cold blood.
This is still in play.
We still have a
shot of getting--
Quiet!
This is how this
is going to work.
You keep your mouth shut.
You never contact Nasry again.
You don't lawyer up.
And the video disappears.
Otherwise, the charge
will be murder.
Well, that was some show.
Here's my take on
how this went down.
You weren't expecting
to be attacked.
You defended your
HVI and your team.
Then your CIA officer bigfoot-ed
you, let Nasry go on her own.
Is that right?
- That is correct.
- Yes, sir.
Is there anything else
I should be aware of?
No, sir.
I still think you
made the wrong call.
You get your own team,
and you make your own calls.
The CIA wants me
to infiltrate you.
They want me to be their mole.
And the bitch who they
gave you the name of someone
in my organization,
someone on the payroll?
Javid Dasmani, your
Pakistani courier.
And now he's dead.
But I still don't trust you.
OK, but she does.
So feed her false
intel through me.
Put him with Andrew Hall.
Who are you?
Where'd you get it?
I took the magazine out.
You know there could still be
a round in that chamber, right?
This is what gets
people like you killed.
This is what kills our kids.
And it happens all the time.
This piece is around $600,
and I know you didn't buy it.
So who gave it to you?
God damn it!
Who gave it to you?
Alex called her.
Any other symptoms?
None.
As far as I'm concerned, you
have the ability to tolerate
operational conditions.
Did you just give
me medical clearance?
You still have to
see the psychiatrist
to confirm that you're
psychologically fit.
Doc, I'm a SEAL.
I haven't been
psychologically fit since I
slid down the birth canal, OK?
Thank you.
Does it bother
you, killing people?
Everyone is surprised at
the moment of their death.
I'm thinking that this
has to be a mistake.
You can see it in their eyes.
Who knocked the
Harvard out of you, man?
Bobby.
Are you OK?
Yeah, I'm good.
I have a sleeper
in the States--
the one who killed the Seals.
Lies, lies, lies.
She's out there!
Waiting to kill whoever I say!
Show me.
Who are you?
It's me, Marissa.
Michael.
Are you still in place?
Yes.
What do you want me to do?
I'm not feeling well.
We're going to kill them.
I need to go home.
All of them.
Ricky can take you.
[phone ringing]
Hey, we're almost there.
Call you in a few?
OK, bye.
I remember you.
Yeah, I waited around all night
for you, and you never showed.
Well, I'm here now.
You'll feel better
once you kill something.
You should ride that
darkness, my man.
That's who you are.
You must be the
great Michael Nasry.
Where's hole?
We need to leave now.
Holy [muted].